obviously probably not pop throws it  once was and it's pretty good a push a  lot of bands who enjoyed making that  kind of music to really think about what  they're doing um you know make some new  sounds make some push it into new areas  which i think is exciting and it's the  exciting time for what you think anyway  you know if you scratch the surface of  what's given to you that's some great  never are there just aren't in maybe the  charts whatever I mean not gonna charts  for ages you know maybe since when I was  a kid was the last time they were in the  charts so um but it's exciting keep  things that are underground usually  bubble with more fresh ideas